sebastian goes like safe spaces you know
and the network goes oh getting your
code they had he said there's an
emotional support little nas's horses
here for emotional support people got
mad cuz its emotional support [ __ ]
animals
i saw a [ __ ] person on video on
instagram with this an emotional support
mini horse hey [ __ ] you
I need the plane to be horse free do you
know why cuz that's a horse the only way
horses should get from one place to a
next is galloping okay you want to put
them in one of those [ __ ] tin little
things that you get a transport them on
a highway fine okay fine but horses
belong in the air as much as smoothies
belong in the air therefore the ground
if horses should be on a plane if horses
should be in the air there would be
Pegasus's airline news US Department of
Transportation rules airlines must allow
miniature horses to fly as service
animals are you [ __ ] absolutely [ __ ]
ass kidding me dude miniature horses
first of all shouldn't there not be
miniature horses
isn't that a [ __ ] thing that humans
made didn't they develop them the whole
things wrong [ __ ] your emotional animals
man okay
amer the result of centuries of
selective breeding k cool leave them on
the ground you're gonna be stressed out
without your mini horse and comfort plus
stay on the [ __ ] ground
beat chillin if you're anxious if you're
that anxious imagine being that [ __ ]
egocentric that you're like well I don't
give a [ __ ] I want to go to Hawaii and I
can't get there without the whole
goddamn cabin smellin like a [ __ ]
manure Hut I swear if I saw a mini horse
on a plane get on a plane and I was oh
even if I was in the back of the plane
and they were in the fact this is me in
the back
Oh for [ __ ] sake in the back are you
[ __ ] me
hey get that horse off though oh [ __ ]
dude I woke up oh my god dude whoa what
happened they say what I say oh by
mistake dude by mistake this happened
and they say what do you mean by mistake
this whole thing happened dude you got a
you got him you got a horse on this
thing on this [ __ ] thing with wings
in the air and they say well it's a mini
horse technically and I go technically
this shouldn't be a thing though right
and that true and I rub their face a
little bit like this and that true huh
and they say well I need it for
emotional support well it's a lot more
stressful now that I'm yelling that
you're right
make this [ __ ] thing gallop you think
that many ass horse wants to be in the
air you think that mini s force wants to
watch [ __ ] Mickey blue eyes with you
on that small TV you think that mini
horse is looking at the [ __ ] TV
select was you oh I don't want to watch
any of these goddamn Chinese movie why
there's so many goddamn Chinese movies
on this airline oh I must go to China a
lot
even having a name for a [ __ ] horses
idiotic straight up even a big horse
that's [ __ ] Charlie the horse nah nah
that's horse yeah but you can ride it
and feed it all right cool it's a big
horse that's what we call him bro that
so there is literally nothing more
annoying than a mini horse on a goddamn
plane literally not somebody could
[ __ ] there could I could have a
passenger next to me that every 15
minutes
rubbed peanut butter in my eyes and that
would be less annoying that somebody
bringing a goddamn mini horse on a plane
dude in there just gonna sit there and
text you know they're gonna get Wi-Fi
and text while they're mini horses right
next to them dude
that's unbelievable what is this world
coming to
said the old guy imagine dude no way
bring a big horse have a big horse on
the plane then that's the only time it's
okay a zebra a [ __ ] giraffe all
crunched over neck all laying down the
[ __ ] side butters come here hi
butters you're an insult come here he's
so scared he's all right butters
yearning so high what do you doing dude
are you it in so come here come here you
know a podcast is going on that's why
you're so scared huh I'm an evil villain